in the loud house things can be well
loud
but underneath all of the noise there
are some subtle references to other
great nickelodeon shows you may have
missed on your first watch through
there are quite a few nods to our
favorite pineapple dwelling sponge as
well as some classic knit shows from way
back when
cleanliness is next to manager linus for
a long time
everyone knew what the number one
nickelodeon show was spongebob
squarepants
then along came the loud house to
overtake the show in the ratings
but don't worry the series found plenty
of ways to pay tribute to our favorite
sea sponge
check out this scene from friend or foe
in this episode lisa got an f in social
skills and has to make a new friend to
boost her grade
first i made one do you notice anything
aquatic in the background
if you weren't thrown off by the fish
tank you may have spotted a poster
featuring some of our favorite ocean
creatures
including a crab starfish squid
and a sponge there's no way this poster
isn't an homage to mr krabs patrick
starr squidward tentacles
and spongebob squarepants himself now
let's take a look back to the very first
episode of the loud house
this series wasted no time when it came
to incorporating hidden references for
fans to spot
check out what happens when the kids
fight over the remote control if you
keep your eyes
open on the television screen you'll see
that at one point a familiar looking
show featuring a smiling sponge and
starfish appear
they may look more like doodle bob
versions but they're definitely supposed
to be spongebob and patrick making a
guest appearance
for this next spongebob squarepants loud
house crossover
you'll need to listen up we spent the
entire first season of the series unable
to get a glimpse of her entire face
but it's her voice we should be paying
attention to now listen
out loud hosted by me read aloud
does that sound familiar to you it's the
kind of voice you might also picture
emerging from a robot created by a
maniacal little plankton
well if it isn't my feeding husband so
did you bring me the
voice actress jill talley provides the
voice for both rita loud
and karen plankton from spongebob
plankton is used to being overshadowed
by spongebob and the success of the
krusty krab
but he's actually had multiple
references in the loud house as well
during luann's episode of listen out
loud she goes over ways to prank your
friends and family using her own
siblings as examples
in addition to teaching preparation
execution escalation
and escape she also mentions a prank
that involves a bucket and chum
she's definitely talking about
plankton's less than successful
restaurant the chum bucket
is fun how much attention do you really
pay to the cute loud house title cards
let's test your episode name knowledge
by talking about one called out of the
picture
do you see any spongebob connections
here in this episode
lisa is devastated over a
soon-to-be-published photo of her that
she desperately doesn't want included in
the yearbook
coach pikowski ruined my life he took
the worst photo of me
ever out of the picture is also the name
of a spongebob episode
in which mr krabs wants to sell
squidward's art without having the
artist himself involved
as if the episode titles weren't enough
both of these episodes aired
the same year in 2017. it's time for
another round of guess that voice actor
can you spot the spongebob crossover
this time we'll start with the voice of
spongebob's troublesome cousin
blackjack who we met in season
did you 5. here to quiver like a
jellyfish any guesses
you just heard the voice of john
dimaggio who voices several loud house
characters
including chunk flip and mr grouse
i'd like to be alone with my lasagna
even if you don't recognize
his name his voice may sound familiar
since he also voices bender on futurama
king zog on disenchantment and many
other popular characters
dude come on man you're totally mad you
may have to hit the pause button this
time
because there are a ton of nickelodeon
references in the episode link or swim
when the louds head to the pool there
are quite a few elderly characters
sitting poolside
do you recognize any of them these are
some classic nick characters
some more beloved than others there's
lou pickles tommy's grandfather from
rugrats as well as grandpa phil from hey
arnold
and who could forget everyone's favorite
uncle iro from avatar the last airbender
there are also a couple of teachers
enjoying their summer breaks including
miss fowle from jimmy neutron
and miss bitters from invader zim how
many of these did you recognize
some of these references are pretty hard
to spot and we have a feeling that this
could be an unofficial one
in the episode space invader lincoln
reveals in the fact that he doesn't have
to share his bedroom just before having
to bunk with lin for the night
can you see anything unusual when
lincoln is tidying up his space when he
empties the trash can you can see a
smiling starfish
on the side of the bucket it doesn't
look exactly like patrick star
but it does look similar to when he
appeared in the first episode
of the loud house is this a reference or
are we just seeing spongebob characters
everywhere
if you're a fan of classic nickelodeon
shows then you definitely appreciated
the loud house episode
legends this entire episode paid tribute
to the beloved nickelodeon game show
legends of the hidden temple which did
indeed have a team called the orange
iguanas
all aboard orange iguanas next stop
orlando
contestants competed in challenges to
gain entry to the hidden temple and a
try
for the chance to win prizes by
completing the obstacle course
if they could get past the shrine of the
silver monkey listen up
fans of the loud house know there's a
lot of music going on in this show
but for now we're going to focus on what
follows the theme song of the loudest
yard
this one goes way back so it's
understandable if you didn't recognize
now that they're men
this tune was also featured in the
spongebob squarepants movie from 2004.
now
here's an even older classic reference
for you so think back to those evenings
watching nick
at night in the loud house episode the
butterfly effect lola gets hit in the
face with a ball which causes her nose
to swell up
this happened to another famous
fictional character do you know who
we're talking about marsha brady who was
struck in the face under similar
circumstances on the brady bunch
and in the brady bunch movie ready oh my
nose
growing up in a big family means there's
space at a premium and this is something
linking is well aware of
in the episode the sweet spot he decides
to stake out the back seat in order to
get the best spot possible during his
family's road trip
clever but do you notice anything
interesting about this scene
feed off the seat lincoln is reading a
magazine that says giant sub with a
picture of a yellow submarine
now this could be a reference to the
famous beetle song
yellow submarine or it could be yet
another spongebob easter egg
after all we've seen sandy get around
underwater using one of those devices
more than once
[Music]
here's another title card test which
famous nickelodeon show
also has an episode entitled oh brother
if you guessed dexter's laboratory
you're right
in the loud house lincoln wishes he had
10 brothers instead of 10 sisters
and lisa shows him what that could look
like spoiler alert
it's not the best dexter only has a
single sister but she manages to cause
about 10 siblings worth of damage to his
laboratory
[Music]
dexter decides to turn dede into a boy
and discovers things with his siblings
really can get worse
in the episode attention deficit lincoln
feels overlooked among his own family
and turns to clyde's fathers for some
much needed encouragement
but when lincoln finally gets the chance
to show off his volcano to his own
family
you might see something interesting
among his materials what do you see here
you may have noticed the bottle of glue
which says tough and this could be a
reference to the cartoon tough puppy
ready for another nod to a cartoon from
way back check out the loud house
episode come sail away
in which the family takes part in a
yearly tradition i haven't had a win in
forever
but that changes today it's our annual
garage sale
lincoln is determined to sell the most
stuff and when he sets up his display
you may see something familiar
any guesses that moose wearing hockey
gear looks an
awful lot like the cartoon character
bullwinkle nickelodeon had their own
version of this classic character on the
show bullwinkles moosarama
my whole life just flashed before my
eyes did you manage to spot any of these
references on your own when watching the
loud house
there are tons of great nickelodeon
easter eggs so let us know about any we
may have missed in the comments section
below
make sure to click on the subscribe
button and turn on your notifications
for more new videos from us here at the
things
bye for now